Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Thus far, with rough and all-unable pen, our bending author hath pursued the story, in little room confining mighty men, mangling by starts the full course of their glory. Small time, but in that small, most greatly lived this star of England, fortune made his sword by which the world's best garden he achieved. So that's William Shakespeare on Henry V. And Tom, in this final episode, we will discuss the fact that it's just a small time in which the star of england most greatly lived but before we get on to the tragic end to the story we should return to the place we ended last time the battlefield
感谢收听《历史的 rest》。想要获取每周独家播客、无广告收听、剧集抢先看以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。至此，我们这位笔拙力竭的作者，伴随着粗糙而无能的文风，在小小的空间里追溯着伟大的身影，时断时续地糟蹋着他们光辉的历程。时间虽短，但在那短短的时光里，这位英格兰之星极其灿烂地活着，命运造就了他的宝剑，凭此他赢得了世上最好的花园。这是威廉·莎士比亚对亨利五世的评价。汤姆，在这最后一集中，我们将讨论这样一个事实：英格兰之星极其灿烂地生活的时间其实很短，但在我们进入这个故事的悲剧结局之前，我们应该回到上一次结束的地方——战场。
of agincourt the mud the corpses the horror i mean the effect of your tour de force performance last time was such that we've just had an absolute tongue lashing from our producer, a French producer. You can tell he's French from his name, Theo Young-Smith, who was appalled by what he said was the chauvinistic lies that had been told about the Battle of Agincourt. You know, let's dwell for a little bit on the horror now, Tom, because Theo wants to feel sad about all the flower of French chivalry. So take us into the mounds of bodies and the mud and the blood and the dismembered limbs and all that sort of stuff. Make Theo happy.
阿金库尔：泥泞、尸体、恐怖。我的意思是，你上次那场精彩绝伦的表演所产生的效果是，我们刚刚被我们的制片人、一位法国制片人狠狠地训斥了一通。你可以从他的名字听出他是法国人——西奥·扬-史密斯（Theo Young-Smith），他对关于阿金库尔战役的沙文主义谎言感到震惊。你知道的，汤姆，现在让我们稍微回味一下当时的恐怖，因为西奥想为法国骑士精神的精华感到悲伤。所以，请把我们带入尸山血海、泥泞和残肢断臂的场景中去吧。让西奥高兴高兴。
I don't think there is any doubt and has ever been any doubt that the scene was horrific and the memory of the horror as well as the glory is a part of what makes Agincourt the totemic battle that it is. Juliet Barker, in her account of the aftermath of the battle, she writes, the sheer scale of the French defeat was genuinely humbling, even frightening. And as you said, there are piles and piles of French dead raised in great mounds along the length of the English line and stretching all the way back to the original French positions. And it's evident that the flower of French chivalry have been slaughtered. And it's not possible to know the precise numbers. And that's partly for obvious reasons. There wasn't a chance for people to go around and count up the corpses,
我认为毫无疑问，也从来没有人怀疑过，当时的场景是极其恐怖的，对恐怖的记忆以及对荣耀的记忆，正是让阿金库尔成为标志性战役的一部分。朱丽叶·巴克（Juliet Barker）在描述战后情况时写道，法国战败的规模之大简直令人感到卑微，甚至令人恐惧。正如你所说，沿着英军战线一直延伸到最初法军阵地，堆积着一堆又一堆的法国死者。很明显，法国骑士精神的精华已经被屠杀殆尽。而且不可能知道确切的数字。部分原因是很显然的：人们根本没有机会四处去数尸体，
but also the sense that the scale of the slaughter was just too overwhelming. So there's a Burgundian chronicler, you know, he's trying to work out how many died and he lists about 300. And then he just kind of throws his hands up and he says, many others I omit for the sake of brevity. And also because one cannot know how to record them all because there were too many of them. But French chroniclers being what they are, obviously they focus on those who are high born who die. And that does give you a sense, I think, of just how stunning a disaster this is for France, because by and large in battles, the well-born do not die.
而且人们也觉得屠杀的规模实在是太压倒性了。所以有个勃艮第的编年史家，你知道的，他在试图算出到底死了多少人，他列出了大约300人。然后他就绝望地摊开双手说道：“为了简便起见，许多其他人我就不记了。而且因为没人知道该如何把他们全记录下来，因为他们实在太多了。”但法国编年史家历来如此，他们显然只关注那些死去的贵族。我认为，这确实让你感受到这场灾难对法国来说是多么惊人的打击，因为通常在战斗中，出身高贵的人是不会死的。
They are protected in their armour. If they're captured, they expect their lives to be conserved. And on both accounts, this isn't the case with Agincourt. Three dukes are dead, among them the Duke of Alençon, the guy who was in command of the second block, the main body of the French army. And there are various stories about he dies. The most popular account, which some historians contest, I see no reason to doubt it, is that he is killed trying to reach Henry, that he gets cut down by Henry's bodyguards as he tries to surrender because the ferocity of his attack has been so great that they're not willing to cut him any quarter. There's also the Duke of Brabant, who's the younger brother of John the Fearless,
他们在盔甲的保护下安然无恙。如果被俘，他们期望自己的生命能得到保全。然而在这两点上，阿金库尔战役却并非如此。三位公爵阵亡，其中包括阿朗松公爵（Duke of Alençon），也就是指挥法军第二方阵、即主力部队的那个人。关于他是怎么死的，有各种各样的说法。最流行的说法——尽管有些历史学家对此有异议，但我认为没有理由怀疑它——是他在试图接近亨利时被杀，当他试图投降时，被亨利的贴身卫士砍倒，因为他的进攻实在太猛烈了，以至于卫士们不肯给他留活路。还有布拉班特公爵（Duke of Brabant），他是无畏者约翰（John the Fearless）的弟弟，
who we mentioned in the last episode. He's the guy who turns up late from brunch and he takes the banner and cuts the hole in it and kind of wears it like a poncho. And because he's not wearing the surcoat of the Duke of Brabant, when Henry gives the order for the prisoners to be killed, he is among the prisoners who get spitted. There's a lesson to us all there. Don't be late for a battle. Yeah, don't hang around having brunch. His younger brother, the Count of Nevers, is also killed. Seven of the French king's cousins are dead.
我们在上一集提到过他。就是那个从早午餐聚会迟到的人，他拿过旗帜在上面剪了个洞，就像穿斗篷一样把它披在身上。因为他没有穿布拉班特公爵的外衣，当亨利下令处决俘虏时，他成了被串起来处决的俘虏之一。这给我们所有人上了一课：打仗可千万别迟到。对，别磨磨蹭蹭去吃早午餐。他的弟弟讷韦尔伯爵（Count of Nevers）也阵亡了。法国国王的七位堂亲丧生。
The constable Charles d'Arbray is dead. The Admiral of France, the Master of the Royal Archers. So that's the cream of the French military high command. There's even an archbishop, the Archbishop of Sens. He dies sword in hand in the midst of a melee. One chronicler describes him as striking blows on every side with the strength of a hectare. Another chronicler says, you know, this is not good behaviour from an archbishop, so he had it coming. He's no Justin Welby. No, he's not.
统帅查尔斯·达布雷（Charles d'Albret）阵亡。法国海军上将、皇家弓箭手总监也阵亡了。这些都是法国军事最高指挥部的精华。甚至还有一位大主教，桑斯大主教（Archbishop of Sens）。他在混战中手握长剑战死沙场。一位编年史家形容他挥舞着赫克尔（Hector）般的力量在各方劈砍。另一位编年史家则说，你知道的，这可不是一个大主教该有的行为，所以他是咎由自取。他可不是贾斯廷·韦尔比（Justin Welby）。不，他不是。
He's more Robert Runcie, whose men nicknamed him Killer, Tank Commander in World War II. Yes, he won the MC. He did. Brilliant. So also lower down through the kind of the structure of local French government. So there are officials called baillis, so bailiffs, and they essentially are the king's administrative representatives. And of the 21 baillis who have office north of the Loire, 12 are killed, so over half. And in Picardy,
他更像是罗伯特·兰西（Robert Runcie），他的手下在二战中给他起了个绰号叫“杀手”，是坦克指挥官。是的，他获得过军功十字勋章。他确实得过。太棒了。同样，通过法国地方政府的层级结构往下看，有一些被称为“巴伊”（baillis）的官员，即法警，他们基本上是国王的行政代表。在卢瓦尔河以北任职的21名巴伊中，有12人被杀，超过了一半。在皮卡第，
which is where the battle has been fought, basically the whole seigneurial class has been wiped out. They've all answered the summons, you know, they've rallied to the flag and they've been destroyed. And in some cases, you know, two generations, in some cases, three generations have been wiped out. So essentially, local government in northern France has been decapitated on the battlefield. So those are the dead. On top of that, there are prisoners who survived. The Duke of Brabant would have been spared if people had known who he was.
也就是发生战斗的地方，基本上整个地主阶级都被消灭了。他们全都响应了召唤，你知道的，他们集结到旗帜下，然后被摧毁了。在某些情况下，两代人，甚至在某些情况下，三代人被彻底抹去。从本质上讲，法国北部的地方政府在战场上被斩首了。这就是死者。除此之外，还有幸存的俘虏。如果人们当时知道布拉班特公爵是谁，他本可以被饶恕。
The highest ranking prisoners have been kind of kept secure. And so estimates of the numbers of prisoners range from about 700 to about 2000. And their ranks include some very notable names. So Boussico, the great paladin of French chivalry who'd been taken prisoner by the Turks after Nicopolis, he's now been taken prisoner again. The most distinguished and in some ways the most tragic of the prisoners is the young Duke of Orléans, due to celebrate his 21st birthday on the 26th of October, so the day after Agincourt, and it's going to be a miserable birthday. So he has been found under a pile of corpses. His surcoat is so soaked with blood that it's difficult for the people who drag him out to
地位最高的一些俘虏被妥善看管起来。因此，对俘虏人数的估计从大约700人到2000人不等。他们的行列中包括一些非常著名的名字。比如布西科（Boucicaut），法国骑士精神的伟大捍卫者，曾在尼科波利斯（Nicopolis）战役后被土耳其人俘虏，现在他又一次被俘了。最杰出、在某种程度上也是最悲惨的俘虏是年轻的奥尔良公爵（Duke of Orléans），他本该在10月26日庆祝自己21岁的生日，也就是阿金库尔战役的第二天，但这注定是一个凄凉的生日。他被发现在一堆尸体下面。他的外衣被血浸得透湿，以至于把他拖出来的人很难
recognise who he is. And his captor is a Kentish knight called Richard Waller, who is knighted for his achievement actually on the battlefield. And he takes, as his coat of arms, the walnut tree that is his family crest with the Duke's shield hanging from it. Oh, that's very good. Yeah. And the Duke of Orléans, not only is he going to have a terrible birthday, he's going to spend the next quarter of a century as a prisoner in English custody. Yeah, because as we will see, Henry will end up signing with the Burgundians. And so therefore, they don't want to let the Duke of Orléans, who would be the leader of the Armagnac side, out.
认出他是谁。他的俘虏是一个名叫理查·沃勒（Richard Waller）的肯特郡骑士，他实际上因在战场上的功绩而被册封为骑士。他把家族徽章上的胡桃树作为自己的纹章，并把公爵的盾牌挂在树枝上。哦，这太棒了。是的。奥尔良公爵不仅将度过一个可怕的生日，而且他将在英国度过长达四分之一个世纪的囚徒生涯。是的，正如我们将看到的，亨利最终将与勃艮第人签约。因此，他们不想放走本可以成为阿尔马尼亚克派领袖的奥尔良公爵。
And so the poor guy, as you say, 25 years, it's the measure of how long he is in England. He's a very distinguished poet. He writes these beautiful poems in French, but he also writes poems in English, years. It's the measure of how long he is in England. He's a very distinguished poet. He writes these beautiful poems in French, but he also writes poems in English, which are pretty good. I mean, they're pretty sophisticated. And for a French nobleman in the 15th century to end up writing English poetry. Listen, the day before your 21st birthday, you're looking forward to your 21st birthday, but actually the next day you'll see your native land as a free man. You'll be what? 46. An intervening period is just a hiatus.
因此这个可怜的家伙，正如你所说，长达25年，这衡量了他在英国呆了多久。他是一位非常杰出的诗人。他用法语写了这些美丽的诗歌，但他也会用英语写诗，一呆就是多年。这衡量了他在英国呆了多久。他是一位非常杰出的诗人。他用法语写了这些美丽的诗歌，但他也会用英语写诗，写得相当不错。我的意思是，它们相当成熟。对于一个15世纪的法国贵族来说，最终竟然用英语写诗。听着，在你21岁生日的前一天，你正期盼着21岁生日的到来，但实际上第二天你才会以自由之身的身份看到你的祖国。你会有多大？46岁。中间的那段时光不过是一段空白。
Yeah. So terrible for him and terrible for the Armagnacs because basically they've been wiped out. John the Fearless has lost two brothers, but the Armagnac, their cream is gone, either dead or prisoner. But I think in a way, the most moving sense of the disaster that has befallen France, it's not in the details of any one of the prisoners or the dead. It's in a poem that was written a year or two after the battle by Alain Chartier, who's not just a poet, but a very loyal servant of the Dauphin, who will end
是的。对他是场悲剧，对阿尔马尼亚克派来说也是场悲剧，因为他们基本上被消灭了。无畏者约翰失去了两个弟弟，但阿尔马尼亚克派的精英全都消失了，要么战死，要么被俘。但我认为，从某种意义上说，最能体现降临在法国身上的灾难的不是任何一个俘虏或死者的细节，而是战后一两年由阿兰·沙蒂埃（Alain Chartier）写的一首诗。他不仅是一位诗人，也是王太子（后来的查理七世，也就是圣女贞德投奔的那位查理六世的小儿子）非常忠诚的仆人。
up becoming Charles VII, the one Joan of Arc comes to, the youngest son of Charles VI. And he writes this poem, the Livre des Quatre Dames, so the Book of the Four Women. And it's four women who are lamenting the fate of their husbands at the Battle of Agincourt. So they say, which of the four of them has the greatest cause for grief? One of them has a husband who's been killed. One of them has a husband who is a prisoner in England. One of them has a husband who's been killed. One of them has a husband who is a prisoner in England. One of them has a husband whose corpse has never been found. But they agree that the lady who has the greatest cause for grief is the fourth one because her husband had run away from the battle and had shown himself a coward. So there you go. The truth is, Dominic,
他写了这首诗《四妇人的书》（Le Livre des Quatre Dames）。诗中有四个妇女在哀叹她们的丈夫在阿金库尔战役中的命运。于是她们说，她们四人中谁的悲伤理由最大？其中一个人的丈夫战死了；另一个人的丈夫在英国成了俘虏；第三个人的丈夫战死了；第四个人的丈夫在英国成了俘虏。其中一个人的尸体从未被找到。但她们一致认为，悲伤理由最大的女士是第四个，因为她的丈夫在战斗中逃跑了，表现得像个懦夫。所以你看。事实是，多米尼克，
that even the English at the spectacle of the slaughter are capable of being moved to tears. Sir Henry's chaplain, who lived through the battle, he wrote, there is not a man with heart of flesh or even of stone who had he seen and pondered on the horrible deaths and bitter wounds of so many Christian men would not have dissolved into tears time and again for grief. Oh, that is moving, Tom.
甚至连英格兰人在目睹这场屠杀时，也会感动得流泪。亨利爵士的随军牧师经历过这场战役，他写道：“没有一个拥有血肉之心甚至铁石心肠的人，在看到并沉思了如此多基督教徒的恐怖死状和痛苦伤口之后，不会为之悲伤得一次又一次地潸然泪下。”哦，那太感人了，汤姆。
Would that be true of you? Yeah, I think there's a time for mourning, but there's also a time to luxuriate in the warm glow of victory. And that presumably is what Henry V is doing right now, right? He believed God would give him the victory and God has absolutely given him everything he wanted. Henry does mourn the dead. He is stunned by it. He does weep for them. But he also feels that God has given him the victory. Absolutely.
你也会这样吗？是的，我认为有哀悼的时候，但也有陶醉在胜利的温暖光辉中的时候。而亨利五世现在大概就是在做这件事吧？他相信上帝会赐予他胜利，而上帝绝对给了他想要的一切。亨利确实在为死者哀悼。他对此感到震惊。他确实为他们哭泣。但他也觉得上帝赐予了他胜利。绝对是这样，
And has backed him in the most spectacular manner possible. And if he mourns the French dead, then the thing that's astonishing is how few English there are to mourn. So in contrast to the slaughter of the French aristocracy, there are really only two magnates who die at Agincourt. One of them is the Duke of York, and one of them is a very young aristocrat, the Earl of Suffolk. And most of the English casualties are archers, so maybe 150 in total, compared to the thousands and thousands of the French. And this victory, I mean, there is no two ways about it. This is a victory that would not have been won without Henry. He's the man who has chosen to balance his army in the way that he has done with an emphasis on archers as opposed
并且以最壮观的方式支持了他。如果说他在为死去的法国人哀悼，那么令人惊奇的是，需要哀悼的英国人竟然是如此之少。因此，与法国贵族的惨遭屠杀形成鲜明对比的是，在阿金库尔阵亡的英格兰显贵实际上只有两人。其中一位是约克公爵（Duke of York），另一位是一位非常年轻的贵族萨福克伯爵（Earl of Suffolk）。大多数英国伤亡人员都是弓箭手，总共大约150人，而法军则是成千上万。这场胜利，我的意思是，毫无疑问，如果没有亨利，这场胜利是赢不到手的。正是他选择以这种方式部署军队，强调弓箭手而不是重装骑士。
to men at arms. It was his choice to march on Calais, knowing that it would risk a battle, offering himself up as a kind of bait, as he did in the battle itself. It's his tactics on the day of the battle that have prevailed over the French. And there's no question that it's his inspirational leadership, I think, that prevents the English line from buckling when that first great clash happens, when the French men at arms run into them, smash into them. And of course, it's not just a judgment on him, it's a judgment on France as well. So while he mourns the individual dead, he does feel that the French have brought this terrible fate on themselves. And in part, this is because they haven't acknowledged him as king, but it's also because of the many atrocities that Henry feels that they have been committing. So famously, anyone who knows the great speech that Henry gives in Shakespeare, this day is called the Feast of Crispian, and it is fought on St. Crispin's Day. And Crispin and Crispinian are two Christian martyrs who were beheaded in the third century in Soissons. And listeners may remember that Soissons is the place that had
是他选择进军加来，明知这会冒着开战的风险，将自己当作某种诱饵，正如他在战斗本身中所做的那样。正是他在战役当天的战术战胜了法军。毫无疑问，正是他鼓舞人心的领导力，我认为，当第一次大冲突爆发、当法国重装骑士冲向他们并猛烈撞击他们时，才阻止了英格兰战线的崩溃。当然，这不仅是对他个人的评价，也是对法国的评价。因此，虽然他在哀悼个别死者，但他确实觉得法国人是将这场可怕的命运招致自身。部分原因是因为他们没有承认他是国王，但也是因为亨利觉得他们一直在犯下许多暴行。正如人们所熟知的，任何熟悉莎士比亚剧中亨利那段伟大演讲的人都知道：这一天被称为克里斯皮安节（Feast of Crispian），它是在圣克里斯皮安节（St. Crispin's Day）那天打响的。而克里斯pin和克里斯皮安是两位基督教殉道者，在公元三世纪于苏瓦松（Soissons）被斩首。听众可能还记得，苏瓦松曾是一个地方，
been brutally ransacked and put to the torch by the Armagnac forces and the Armagnac leaders are all now dead. And so the sense that the quality of supernatural intervention has been shimmering over the battlefield is very strong. And there are English soldiers in the battle who say that they had seen St. George visible in the sky. I think that's very strong. And there are English soldiers in the battle who say that they had seen St. George visible in the sky. I think that's very likely. Well, I think completely. And Henry's chaplain is very clear on this. Far be it, he writes, from our people to ascribe the triumph to their own glory or strength, rather let it be ascribed to God alone, which I think is a commendable display of modesty. God, Henry and Welsh archers. People call it the Holy Trinity,
曾被阿尔马尼亚克军队残酷劫掠并付之一炬，而阿尔马尼亚克的领导人们现在都已经死了。因此，超自然干涉的特质在战场上闪耀的感觉非常强烈。参战的英国士兵中有人说他们看到圣乔治显灵在天空中。我认为这非常强烈。参战的英国士兵中有人说他们看到圣乔治显灵在天空中。我认为这很有可能。哦，我认为完全如此。亨利的牧师对此非常明确。他写道：“远避我们的人民，莫将胜利归功于他们自己的荣耀或力量，而应将之完全归功于上帝。”我认为这表现出了值得称赞的谦逊。上帝、亨利和威尔士弓箭手。人们称之为三位一体，
don't they? And it's an unbeatable combination. Yes. So Henry might have been tempted to leave the battlefield immediately because of course he is still in danger. His men are exhausted. There aren't very many of them. There are still lots of French contingents all over the place. But he decides that after that battle and after the march that they've had, the sleepless night, they really need to get their rest. And so they bed down, despite the fact that obviously the stench of carrion is hideous in the air. He orders the bodies of York and Suffolk to be cut up into four, to be boiled so that all the flesh falls off the bones, and the bones are then put in caskets so that they can be taken to England for Christian burial. The English soldiers fan out across the battlefield, stripping the dead of their valuables, jewellery, armour, weapons. And the problem is there's so
不是吗？这是一个不可战胜的组合。是的。所以亨利本可能会经不住诱惑立即离开战场，因为当然他仍然处于危险之中。他的手下已经精疲力竭。他们人数不多。周围仍然到处都是法国军队的分遣队。但他决定，经过那场战斗和他们的行军以及不眠之夜后，他们真的需要好好休息一下。因此，尽管空气中腐尸的恶臭令人作呕，他们还是卧倒休息了。他下令将约克和萨福克两人的尸体切成四块，煮沸以便让所有的肉脱落骨头，然后将骨头放入小盒子里，以便运回英国进行基督教安葬。英国士兵散布在战场各处，剥去死者身上的贵重物品、珠宝、盔甲和武器。问题在于，有
much to take that it's just impossible for it all to be taken with the army to Calais. So Henry orders what can't be taken to be piled up in a barn, and he then sets the barn on fire so that these weapons and armor can't be used by the enemy. And then once the English have taken what they want to take, then all the locals pile in. So they've already got the true cross and the crown jewels and everything. And now they're going in and they're taking what else they can. So I mentioned earlier that the French are very keen on giving, certainly the seigneurial class are keen on giving their sons the names of Arthurian heroes. And it always reminds me of a passage in the Mort d'Arthur, Thomas Mallory's account of the Arthurian legends, where Arthur and Mordred meet in the great battle at the end of the book. All
太多的东西要拿，以至于全军根本无法将它们全部带到加来。于是亨利下令将无法带走的东西堆在一个谷仓里，然后放火烧了谷仓，这样这些武器和盔甲就不会被敌人利用。接着，一旦英国人拿走了他们想拿的东西，当地人便蜂拥而上。他们已经拿走了真十字架、王冠珠宝和所有东西，现在他们正涌进去拿走他们还能拿的其他东西。所以我前面提到过，法国人非常热衷于给——当然是地主阶级热衷于给他们的儿子起亚瑟王传奇英雄的名字。这总是让我想起《亚瑟王之死》（Mort d'Arthur）中的一个片段，那是托马斯·马洛里（Thomas Mallory）对亚瑟王传奇的描述，亚瑟和莫德雷德在书尾的那场大战中相遇。所有
the knights of the round table slaughter each other. And then he gives this account of how the peasants come out and start stripping the dead. And it's almost the only time that peasants are mentioned in the whole of the Mort Dartha. And this sense that a similar fate is being visited on these knights with their Arthurian names, that they are now just lumps of flesh to be stripped of their valuables by peasants. Yeah, it's a very unsentimental, unglamorous end, isn't it? Obviously, they've got their baggage train and the English can pile into that to get all the food when they only had eight days food. And now they've finally got all the food they want and the bedding and stuff. And Henry is quite chivalrous towards his captives, the ones he hasn't killed. He is. There's a much later account that says that his French captives serve him at dinner. But I think this is unlikely to be true because it is so late. The more contemporaneous reports say that he treats
圆桌骑士都互相残杀。然后他描述了农民们出来开始剥死人衣服的情景。这几乎是整个《亚瑟王之死》中唯一一次提到农民。这种感觉是，同样的命运也降临在了这些有着亚瑟王名字的骑士身上，他们现在只是任由农民剥去身上贵重物品的一块块肉。是的，这是一个非常无情、毫无光彩的结局，不是吗？显而易见，他们有辎重车队，英国人可以涌入其中获取所有的食物，而在当时他们只有八天的食物。现在他们终于得到了所有想要的食物、被褥之类的东西。而且亨利对他的俘虏相当有骑士风度，对那些他没杀的人。他是的。有一个后世的记载说，他的法国俘虏在晚宴上侍奉他。但我认为这不太可能是真的，因为时间隔得太久了。更具当代性的报告说，他亲切地对待
them graciously, that they are served dinner, but he does kind of basically give them a lecture and say, you brought it on your own heads. And the next morning at dawn, he takes them out across the battlefield so that they can see, as he sees it, the consequences of their refusal to accept him as king. And then he and his army set off for Calais and they're so loaded down that it takes them three days to cover the 40 odd miles. And on the 29th of October, Henry arrives at Calais and it's a triumphant arrival. And it's on the same day that news of Agincourt reaches London. And Henry has been lost for several days in the wilds of France. And so very dark rumours have been spreading. And therefore the news of the victory is greeted with all the
他们，为他们提供晚宴，但他基本上还是对他们进行了一番说教，说道：“这是你们咎由自取。”第二天黎明时分，他带着他们穿过战场，让他们亲眼看到——在他看来——他们拒绝接受他为国王所造成的后果。随后，他和他的军队动身前往加来，由于负重过重，他们花了三天时间才走完这四十多英里。10月29日，亨利抵达加来，这是一场凯旋的抵达。就在同一天，阿金库尔战役的消息传到了伦敦。由于亨利在法国荒野中失踪了好几天，
more kind of rapture and joy. Henry stays in Calais a couple of weeks to order the situation there. Then on the 16th of November, he lands at Dover in a snowstorm, pauses at Canterbury to offer up prayers there and to pay his respects both to the Black Prince who's buried there and his father, Henry IV, who is buried alongside the Black Prince. And on the 22nd of November, he is received on Blackheath on the road from Kent outside London, where what Tyler and all his gang had assembled during the Peasants' Revolt. But now Henry is being greeted by the mayor, by the aldermen, by several thousand liverymen, all in their kind of formal attire. And then at 10 o'clock, he enters London and absolute exuberant celebrations. And Shakespeare in his play compares it to a Roman triumph,
各种极其黑暗的谣言四处流传。因此，胜利的消息受到了加倍的狂喜和欢乐的迎接。亨利在加来逗留了几个星期，以整顿那里的局势。接着在11月16日，他在一场大雪中在多佛登陆，在坎特伯雷停留祈祷，并向安葬在那里的黑太子以及葬在黑太子身旁的他的父亲亨利四世致敬。11月22日，他在伦敦郊外肯特路上的布莱克希思（Blackheath）受到欢迎，当年瓦特·泰勒（Wat Tyler）和他的同伙在农民起义期间曾聚集在那里。但现在，亨利受到市长、市议员以及数千名身着正式礼服的行会成员的迎接。然后在10点钟，他进入伦敦，受到了狂热的庆祝。莎士比亚在他的戏剧中将其比作罗马式的凯旋，
not actually accurate because Henry is not with his army. The rest of his army has kind of fanned out and the archers have gone back to their villages. The magnates have gone back to their castles. But Henry does enter surrounded by his captives. And there are all these kind of great mechanical tableau everywhere. There's a representation of David and Goliath. So again, you have maybe the earliest public manifestation of this idea that England has won against overwhelming odds. And Jonathan Sumption, in his account of this, he describes
实际上并不准确，因为亨利并不是和他的军队在一起。他的军队的其他部分已经散开，弓箭手回到了他们的村庄，显贵们回到了他们的城堡。但亨利确实在俘虏的簇拥下进城了。到处都是各种巨大的机械布景。有一个大卫和歌利亚的场景。所以，你再次看到了这种思想最早的公开表现——即英格兰在悬殊的实力对比下取得了胜利。乔纳森·萨姆逊（Jonathan Sumption）在对此事的描述中，他描述了
the mottos that are kind of emblazoned over the city of London. And it includes even, blessed is he who comes in the name of the Lord. And Sumption writes, the implicit references to Christ entering Jerusalem can have escaped no one. Here was a new England, the chosen instrument of God's will. So this quality of religiosity that is a character of Henry's militarism, it's there in the moment of triumph as in his moment of danger. And for Henry, so to remind everybody, his father Henry IV had killed Richard II and taken the throne. Their regime, the Lancastrian regime, had been insecure from day one all the way through. I mean, the Battle of Shrewsbury, there'd been plots and conspiracies. And one reason, arguably, why Henry pressed his case in France with such urgency
那些印在伦敦城上的座右铭。其中甚至包括“奉主名来的是应当称颂的”。萨姆逊写道：“对基督进入耶路撒冷的含蓄引用是任何人无法逃脱的。这里是一个新英格兰，是上帝意志选择的工具。”因此，这种构成亨利军国主义特征的宗教狂热，在凯旋的时刻和在危险的时刻一样存在。对亨利来说，为了提醒大家，他的父亲亨利四世曾杀死理查二世并夺取了王位。他们的政权，兰开斯特政权，从第一天起就一直是不稳定的。我的意思是，在什鲁斯伯里战役（Battle of Shrewsbury）中，曾发生过各种阴谋和密谋。一个可以说是亨利如此急迫地在法国据理力争的原因是，
was he felt he needed to basically buy legitimacy for his regime. And he has that now, hasn't he? He has, by rallying the English people against that ancestral enemy, he has ensured total stability for his regime for at least a generation. Yes. So while he was away and all these dark rumours that his army had been wiped out, he'd been taken captive or killed, were swirling around England, there were people who were saying, he's an
他觉得自己需要为自己的政权买下合法性。而他现在得到了，不是吗？通过将英格兰人民团结在那个祖传敌人周围，他确保了自己政权至少长达一代人的绝对稳定。是的。因此，当他不在国内、而全英国都在流传着他的军队被全歼、他已被俘或被杀的黑暗谣言时，有人说他是
illegitimate king, this is the punishment of God on him. But of course, it's completely turned around. And as you say, there will be no further internal insurrections or sedition against the Lancastrian regime until, what, kind of 1450. And actually, Tom, although the Wars of the Roses are coming much later on,
一个非法的国王，这是上帝对他的惩罚。但当然，情况完全逆转了。正如你所说，直到大约1450年，兰开斯特政权都不会再出现内部叛乱或煽动叛乱。而且事实上，汤姆，尽管玫瑰战争来得很晚，
the fact that Henry V dies young and his successor is, what, nine months old? And the fact that there are then no revolts for decades tells you about the importance of the legacy of Agincourt. I mean, that is the ultimate testament to Henry V's success at Agincourt. Yes, and it's a popular success. The idea that, you know, it's the archers what won it is an important part of the way that the propaganda works for Henry. And he makes a conscious attempt to associate Agincourt with a kind of popular sense of patriotism. So one of the things that he does, you know, we did an episode on St. George.
但亨利五世英年早逝、他的继任者只有九个月大这一事实，以及随后几十年里没有发生叛乱的事实，向你说明了阿金库尔传奇的重要性。我的意思是，那是对亨利五世在阿金库尔取得的成功的终极证明。是的，这是一场民众的胜利。“是弓箭手赢得了这场战争”这种观点是亨利宣传工作运作方式的重要组成部分。他有意识地试图将阿金库尔与一种普遍的爱国主义情绪联系起来。所以他做的事情之一——我们曾做过一集关于圣乔治的节目。
This is where St. George really gets enshrined in the calendar of saints. He gets the Archbishop of Canterbury to say that St. George's Day will be celebrated kind of on a level with Christmas Day or Easter. It's that holy. But also very shrewdly, you know, he's been fighting against the Welsh, but he's now had Welsh bowmen with him on campaign. He wants to make the Welsh feel a part of this victory as well. And so he fixes that St. David's Day will also rank on that level. So it's very clever, very thoughtful. And isn't that another clue explaining why in Britain, Agincourt has, dare I say, a kind of a sacred status
正是在这里，圣乔治真正被奉为圣历中的圣徒。他让坎特伯雷大主教宣布，圣乔治节的庆祝规格将与圣诞节或复活节持平。它是如此神圣。而且非常精明的是，你知道的，他一直在与威尔士人作战，但他现在在战役中有了威尔士弓兵。他也想让威尔士人觉得他们是这场胜利的一部分。因此他规定圣大卫节（St. David's Day）也将享有同等级别的地位。所以这非常聪明，非常体贴。这难道不是另一个线索，解释了为什么在英国，阿金库尔——我敢说——拥有某种
that sets it apart from Cressy and Poitier. I mean, those were tremendous victories. But most people, I'm guessing, in Britain have probably never really heard of them. Whereas everybody's heard of Agincourt. It's entered the popular lexicon. And is that, do you think, not just because of Shakespeare, but also because even back then in 1415, Henry V is embedding Agincourt in the popular consciousness as a triumph, not just of the king and his knights, but of the nation, as it were. Yeah, I absolutely do. And I also think that the
神圣的地位，使它区别于克雷西和普瓦捷？我的意思是，那些都是巨大的胜利。但我猜英国大多数人可能从未真正听说过它们。而每个人都听说过阿金库尔。它已经进入了大众词汇。你认为这不仅仅是因为莎士比亚，还因为早在1415年，亨利五世就已经将阿金库尔植入大众意识中，将其视为不仅属于国王和骑士、更是属于整个国家的胜利吗？是的，我绝对这么认为。而且我也认为，
English preserve a memory of this as a time when England, which is relative, say, to France or the empire, a very small, marginal kingdom, that it had achieved great things. So, you know, small time, but in that small, most greatly lived this star of England, Shakespeare's lines in his epilogue to the play. And there is evidence for this in the year that follows Agincourt, say 1416, when Henry hosts Sigismund, who is the emperor elect on a four month visit. And Sigismund had previously been to Paris and hadn't gone on well there at all, had left very disgruntled. But he thinks Henry V is brilliant,
英格兰人将这段记忆保留为这样一个时代：当时与法国或帝国相比，英格兰是一个非常渺小、边缘化的王国，但它却取得了伟大的成就。所以，正如莎士比亚在剧作尾声中的台词所说：“时间虽短，但在那短短的时光里，这位英格兰之星极其灿烂地活着。”阿金库尔之后的第二年，即1416年，当亨利接待前来为期四个月访问的候任皇帝西吉斯蒙德（Sigismund）时，就有证据证明了这一点。西吉斯蒙德以前去过巴黎，在那里进展一点也不顺利，带着极大的不满离开了。但他认为亨利五世太棒了，
absolutely loves him. And Sigismund is made a knight of the garter, which reflects very well, of course, on English chivalry. And he responds by giving Henry the heart of St. George. The heart of St. George. Yeah.
绝对喜欢他。西吉斯蒙德被授予嘉德骑士勋章，这当然为英国的骑士精神增添了光彩。作为回报，他将圣乔治的心脏赠予了亨利。圣乔治的心脏？是的。
So that's quite a gift, isn't it? Yeah. Preserved ever since the days of the Roman Empire in what is now Turkey. No, in what's now Israel. Yeah. And so they get on tremendously well. They become great mates and they sign a treaty, the Treaty of Canterbury. And this is great for Henry because basically by the terms of the treaty,
那真是件大礼，不是吗？是的。自罗马帝国时期以来一直被保存在现在是土耳其的某个地方。不，是在现在的以色列。是的。所以他们相处得极好。他们成了好朋友，并签署了一份条约——《坎特伯雷条约》（Treaty of Canterbury）。这对亨利来说太棒了，因为基本上根据条约条款，
both kings recognise the right of the other to pursue territorial claims against the French. So essentially, it's implicit acknowledgement by Sigismund that Henry is the rightful king of France. And he now has kind of imperial approval, imperial backing for his war. And there is no question that this war is going to be continued. There's no point for Henry of winning Agincourt if he doesn't then leverage it to prosecute his original plan, which was to conquer Normandy at the very least, and maybe to use that as a stepping stone to the conquest of further territories and maybe, you know, in his wildest dreams, the Kingdom of France itself. And he is now in a very strong position. So he's got
两位国王都承认对方对法国领土提出领土主张的权利。因此，本质上这是西吉斯蒙德对亨利是法国合法国王的默许。他现在拥有对其战争的帝国批准和帝国支持。毫无疑问，这场战争将继续下去。如果亨利赢得阿金库尔后不利用它来推进他最初的计划，那么赢得这场战役就毫无意义了。他最初的计划是至少征服诺曼底，并可能以此为跳板去征服更多领土，甚至在最大胆的梦想中，征服法兰西王国本身。他现在处于一个非常有利的地位。所以他拥有了
internal stability, he's got his international allies. And of course, he has a port which is situated on the Normandy coast in the form of Harfleur. One of the reasons that he had left Harfleur to march to Calais, thereby risking battle, was that he wanted to draw the French off Harfleur at a time when the walls were very damaged. These are being repaired over the course of 1415 into 1416. And on the 15th of August, 1416, actually while Sigismund is still in England, the Duke of Bedford, Henry's younger brother, sails with a fleet to Harfleur, where he meets with a French fleet that is trying to capture Harfleur back. Very brutal battle, but he wins it. And in the judgment of Chris Ormond, who is Henry's biographer, he writes that this was in its
国内稳定，他拥有了国际盟友。当然，他还有一个位于诺曼底海岸的港口——哈弗勒尔（Harfleur）。他离开哈弗勒尔去进军加来从而冒着交战风险的原因之一，就是想在城墙严重受损的时候将法军从哈弗勒尔引开。这些城墙在1415年到1416年期间得到了修复。1416年8月15日，实际上就在西吉斯蒙德还在英国时，亨利的弟弟贝德福德公爵（Duke of Bedford）率领舰队驶向哈弗勒尔，在那里遇到了一支试图夺回哈弗勒尔的法国舰队。这是一场非常残酷的战斗，但他赢了。用亨利传记作家克里斯·奥蒙德（Chris Ormond）的话来说，他写道，这是在
effects the most telling of the few naval battles of the Hundred Years' War. And the reason for that is that it secures Harfleur for good. It enables the English to complete the sweeping of French pirates from the Channel and thereby ensures that Henry has ready access to the potential battlefields of Normandy. Also, he has money, which of course Henry from a very young age has understood is key to the making of war because Parliament is so impressed by Agincourt that they respond to Henry's requests for money with incredible generosity, allow him loads of new taxes. And amazingly, they even grant him the customs duty on imports and exports, which They respond to Henry's requests for money with incredible generosity, allow him loads of new taxes. And amazingly, they even grant him the customs duty on imports and exports, which is
影响上百年战争中少数几次海战中最具决定性的一场。原因在于它永久地确保了哈弗勒尔的安全。它使英国人能够彻底清除海峡中的法国海盗，从而确保了亨利能够随时进入诺曼底的潜在战场。此外，他拥有资金。亨利从很小的时候就明白，资金是发动战争的关键，因为议会对阿金库尔战役印象如此深刻，以至于他们以惊人的慷慨回应了亨利对资金的需求，批准了大量的新税收。令人惊叹的是，他们甚至授予了他进出口关税的征收权——
normally very closely and jealously guarded by Parliament. They allow him to have that for life. And it's a statement of trust. We have confidence in you that you will not betray our trust and that you will use this income sensibly. So although Henry doesn't go to France in 1416, although a whole year passes and then another year, and it's not until 1417 that he's ready to embark again for Normandy, he's doing what he always does, which is to prepare and prepare and prepare. And he can do this partly because he knows that there's no point in launching this campaign unless he has money and cash and international backing behind him. But it's also because in France, the situation is utterly dire. Okay, well, let's find out after the break what's
这通常是议会极其严密、嫉妒般守护的权力。他们允许他终身拥有这项权力。这是一份信任的声明。我们对你充满信心，相信你不会辜负我们的信任，你会明智地使用这笔收入。因此，尽管亨利在1416年没有去法国，尽管整整一年过去又是一年，直到1417年他才准备再次启程前往诺曼底，但他一直在做他一直以来都在做的事情，那就是不断地准备、准备、再准备。他能做到这一点，部分是因为他知道，除非他有资金、现金和国际支持在背后支撑，否则发动这场战役毫无意义。但这也是因为在法国，局势已经彻底恶化了。好吧，让我们在休息后了解一下法国一直在发生什么，以及亨利五世接下来将如何利用……therestisentertainment.com，那是therestisentertainment.com。哦天哪，为什么这个不幸又顽固的国家不服从这些神圣的判决呢？如此众多且如此可怕。这是亨利五世的大法官说的，他在1416年3月对议会发表了讲话。当时议会准备投票授予国王巨额补贴，以便在法国重开战役。大法官实际上是在说，法国人一再藐视上帝的法律，他们显然正在因此受到惩罚，但他们就是不肯吸取教训。实际上，持这种观点的并不只有他一人，对吧？因为法国有相当多的人自己也这么认为。他们认为亨利五世、阿金库尔战役
been going on in France and what Henry V does next to capital rest is entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com oh god why does this wretched and stiff-necked nation not obey these divine sentences so many and so terrible so that was the chancellor of henry v and he was talking to parliament in march 1416 parliament was poised to vote the king massive subsidies to renew the war in france and what the chancellor is effectively saying is the french have consistently flouted god's laws and they're being punished for it very obviously but they just will not learn and actually he's not alone in thinking that is he because quite a lot of people in France think that themselves they think Henry V and the Battle of Agincourt
以及英国人是上帝对他们所有罪孽的惩罚，而这方面的证据就是，随着法国继续犯罪，法国的头条新闻变得越来越糟。是的。因此，说阿金库尔有助于稳定法国是站不住脚的。查尔斯·达布雷（Charles d'Albret）作为统帅在阿金库尔阵亡了。所以他必须被替换。显而易见的人选应该是无畏者约翰，也就是缺席了阿金库尔战役的勃艮第公爵。但王太子无法说服自己这样做。他讨厌无畏者约翰。于是他转向了阿尔马尼亚克伯爵，即奥尔良查尔斯的岳父。是的，基本上他是阿尔马尼亚克派中仅存的最后一人了，对吗？
and the English are God's punishment for all of their sins and evidence for that is the fact that as France continues to sin, so the headlines for France get worse and worse. Yes. So Agincourt is not helpful in stabilizing France. It's fair to say. So Charles d'Albray, the constable, had died at Agincourt. And so he has to be replaced. And the obvious person to replace him would be John the Fearless, the Duke of Burgundy, who had sat out the Battle of Agincourt. But the Dauphin can't bring himself to do this. He hates John the Fearless. And so he turns to the Count of Armagnac, Charles of Orléans' father-in-law. Yeah, who's the last man standing of the Armagnac faction, basically, is he?
差不多是这样，是的，因为其余的人要么被杀，要么被俘。显然，这意味着王太子实际上是再次向勃艮第宣战，因为阿尔马尼亚克派和勃艮第派互相仇恨。没错。这就是一直在打内战的两派。接着在1415年12月18日，王太子去世了。所以我提到过他在阿金库尔战役期间生病了，这可能是他没有实际参战的原因之一。所以他死于痢疾。你想知道一个阿尔马尼亚克编年史家是怎么写的吗？我见过，就像我们某些不太好说话的评论一样：浮夸、懒散、无用、不作为且胆小。
Pretty much, yes, because all the rest have been either killed or captured. And obviously, this means that the Dauphin is effectively declaring war again on Burgundy because the Armagnacs and the Burgundians hate each other. Right. These are the two sides who've been fighting the civil war. And then on the 18th of December, 1415, the Dauphin dies. So I mentioned that he'd been ill during the Ahen core campaign which may be one of the reasons he didn't actually fight in the battle so he dies of dysentery and do you want to know what an armagnac chronicler wrote i've seen it it's like some of our less obliging reviews grandiloquent idle useless inactive and timid
是的，这位评论家是怎么说的？是的，而且这其实是出自一个阿尔马尼亚克人之口，所以那是来自他朋友的评价。是的，他被他的弟弟让（Jean）取代成为王太子。我读一下乔纳森·萨姆逊（Jonathan Sumption）对他的评价：他是一个 sickly 的年轻人，缺乏政治经验，几乎完全不了解法国宫廷的派系政治。
yeah what did this critic say yeah and that's from an armagnac actually so that is from one of his friends yes it is and so he's replaced as the dauphin by his younger brother who's called jean and i'll read you what sumption jonathan sumption says about him he was a sickly young man without political experience and almost entirely ignorant of the factional politics of the french court and And the king himself, Charles VI, is now pretty much permanently mad. Yeah, made of glass. So the whole of the kind of the commanding structures of the French state are in an absolutely terrible way. The Count of Armagnac, he's faced with this dump fire and his approach
而国王查理六世本人现在几乎是永久性地疯了。是的，像玻璃做的一样。因此，法国国家的所有指挥结构都处于极其糟糕的状态。阿尔马尼亚克伯爵面对这个烂摊子，他的应对方法是
is to throw petrol on it. So what he does, he comes into Paris and he stages a bloody purge of all his many enemies. So some are put to death, some are imprisoned, some exiled. And the people he particularly goes after are the butchers. So people who've listened to this whole series may remember the cabochiers, the white-haired hoods. So he goes after them. He abolishes all their privileges. He demolishes their headquarters. So that goes after them. He abolishes all their privileges. He demolishes
往上面浇汽油。所以他做的是，他来到巴黎，对他的众多敌人进行了血腥的清洗。因此，一些人被处死，一些人被监禁，一些人被流放。他特别针对的目标是屠夫们。听完整集节目的听众可能还记得卡博香派（Cabochiens），即白头罩派。所以他针对他们。他废除了他们所有的特权。他拆毁了他们的总部。所以这并没有为他赢得民心。在接下来的两年里，巴黎感觉就像一座被占领的城市。它充满怨恨、痛苦，对阿尔马尼亚克的统治充满敌意。巴黎的许多人开始想，好吧，英国人毕竟是英国人，我们讨厌他们，但他们肯定不会像阿尔马尼亚克人那样坏吧。至少亨利如果来了，会给我们带来秩序和公正，因为人们有一种感觉，即亨利虽然严厉，但毕竟是一个公正的人。正当这一切发生时，勃艮第公爵无畏者约翰也在进行调兵遣将。1416年10月，亨利和西吉斯蒙德渡海前往加来，在那里与无畏者约翰会面。谈判的细节被严格保密，但大体轮廓相当清晰。基本上，约翰将协助亨利，
their headquarters. So that's not winning him hearts and minds. And for the next two years, Paris feels like an occupied city. It's resentful. It's embittered. It's hostile to Armagnac's rule. And many people in Paris are starting to think, well, the English are English, we hate them, but surely they can't be as bad as the Armagnacs. And at least Henry, if he comes, would give us order and justice because there is a sense that Henry is, if hard, nevertheless, a just man. And while this is going on, John the Fearless, the Duke of Burgundy, is also on manoeuvres. So October 1416, Henry and Sigismund cross to Calais, where they meet with John the Fearless. And the details of the negotiations are kept secret, but the outline is pretty clear. Basically, that John will help Henry,
他们的总部。所以这并不能赢得民心。在接下来的两年里，巴黎感觉就像一座被占领的城市。这里充满了怨恨、痛苦，对阿尔马尼亚克的统治充满敌意。许多巴黎人开始觉得，好吧，英国人就是英国人，我们讨厌他们，但他们肯定不会像阿尔马尼亚克人那样坏。而且至少亨利如果来了，会给我们带来秩序和公正，因为人们有一种感觉，亨利虽然严厉，但毕竟是一个公正的人。正当这一切发生时，无畏的约翰，也就是勃艮第公爵，也在排兵布阵。因此，在1416年10月，亨利和西吉斯蒙德渡海来到加来，在那里与无畏的约翰会面。谈判的细节被秘而不宣，但大致轮廓非常清晰。基本上，约翰将协助亨利，
but not openly, because he's a peer of the French kingdom. He doesn't want to come out of the closet as yet. However, should Henry reach the stage where he could legitimately be acknowledged as king of France, John the Fearless will come in behind him. So basically, Henry needs to hit a certain benchmark, as it were, of French territory. He does, yes. And so the implications for Henry, you know, this is tremendous. He's now at the very least neutralized the most powerful magnate in France. And because he knows that this magnate is waiting for him to show that he's worthy to be king, he has every incentive to crack on with the conquest of Normandy, which is exactly what he does. So Henry lands back in Normandy on the 1st of August
但不是公开的，因为他是法国王国的同辈贵族。他还不想公开出柜。然而，如果亨利达到可以合法承认自己为法国国王的阶段，无畏的约翰就会支持他。所以基本上，亨利需要达到某种基准，也就是法国领土的基准。他的确达到了。因此，对亨利来说，这意味着极其重大。他现在至少已经中和了法国最有权势的权贵。而且因为他知道这位权贵在等他证明自己配得上做国王，他有充分的动力继续征服诺曼底，而这正是他所做的。因此，亨利于8月1日再次在诺曼底登陆
1417. This time he has 10,000 men. So it's not quite as large as his previous expedition, but that's fine because there's no one now to oppose him. The French state is basically bankrupt. John the Fearless is kind of prowling around with his own army of 10,000 men. And what he does as Henry fans out across Normandy, what John the Fearless does is to capture a kind of screen of towns between Paris and Normandy that will effectively mean it's impossible for the Armagnacs to come out and confront Henry. So effectively now we have the Armagnacs in the capital and we have two kind of rival, but also kind of allied armies,
1417年。这一次他有10,000人。所以规模没有他之前的远征那么大，但这没关系，因为现在没有人能抵抗他了。法国政府基本上已经破产了。无畏的约翰带着他自己10,000人的军队在各处游荡。当亨利在诺曼底展开时，无畏的约翰所做的是占领巴黎和诺曼底之间的一道城镇屏障，这实际上意味着阿马尼亚克派不可能出来与亨利对抗。所以实际上现在阿马尼亚克派在首都，我们有两种敌对但又某种程度上结盟的军队，
the English and the Burgundians, who are kind of just rampaging around the French countryside in northern France. That's basically it, isn't it? Yeah, basically. And Henry's target is to conquer Normandy, which of course had been the Duchy of Willing the Conqueror. And listeners who've heard the whole series may remember that Henry had been emphasising his interest in the Duchy of Normandy. The official title had long since gone into abeyance, but he'd been hinting that he wants to get it back. And so he makes a point of conquering fortress and town after fortress and town. And many of these have great resonances for anyone familiar with the old days of William the Conqueror. So he conquers Caen, where there is a
英格兰人和勃艮第人，他们只是在法国北部乡村横冲直撞。基本上就是这样，对吧？是的，基本上是这样。亨利的目标是征服诺曼底，这当然曾是征服者威廉的公国。听完整系列的听众可能还记得，亨利一直强调他对诺曼底公国的兴趣。官方头衔早就废止了，但他一直暗示他想把它拿回来。因此，他特地攻克了一座又一座的堡垒和城镇。其中许多对熟悉征服者威廉旧日历史的人来说都具有极大的共鸣。所以他征服了卡昂，那里有一座
great castle that had been built by William. He conquers Falaise, which had been William the Conqueror's birthplace. And then his great, in some ways, a military feat comparable to Agincourt. I mean, an astonishing military feat. He lays siege to Rouen, which is by miles the largest town that the English ever lay siege to, let alone capture, in the whole of the Hundred Years' War. And it's very long. It's very long, it's very brutal, it lasts half a year. The news of it is followed across Christendom, as though they're following an ongoing sporting contest or something. It lasts from July 1418
威廉建造的宏伟城堡。他征服了法莱斯，那是征服者威廉的出生地。然后是他伟大的、在某些方面可与阿琴库尔战役相媲美的军事壮举。我的意思是，这是一次惊人的军事壮举。他围攻了鲁昂，这是英格兰人在整个百年战争中围攻甚至攻占的规模最大的城镇，而且远远超过其他城镇。而且时间非常长。非常长，非常残酷，持续了半年之久。整个基督教世界都在关注它的消息，就像在关注一场正在进行的体育比赛一样。它从1418年7月持续到
to January 1419. With Rouen conquered, this is the ancestral capital of the Dukes of Normandy. Henry can now consider himself heir to William the Conqueror for real. And quite aside from the propagandistic benefits of this, Rouen commands both the upper and the lower reaches of the River Seine. And of course, Paris is on the Seine, and so Henry is now in a position to throttle the access of the French capital to the sea. So we're now in the spring of 1419. It's all going well for Henry. And what's even better is that in the last couple of years, and indeed in 1419 itself, French politics already, you know, blood-stained, crazed,ious faction ridden turns i mean if it were possible
1419年1月。随着鲁昂的征服，这是诺曼底公爵的祖传首都。亨利现在可以真正把自己当成征服者威廉的继承人了。抛开这带来的宣传好处不谈，鲁昂控制着塞纳河的上游和下游。当然，巴黎就在塞纳河畔，所以亨利现在有能力切断法国首都通往海洋的通道。所以我们现在处于1419年春季。一切对亨利来说都很顺利。更好的是，在过去的几年里，特别是1419年本身，法国政治本来就已经血腥、疯狂、派系林立，现在变得——我的意思是，如果可能的话，
even more into a kind of george rr martin bloodbath doesn't it yeah because you'd think maybe not enough dofans have died so let's kill another one so this hapless jean the dofan who'd succeeded the podgy dofan he gets an abscess on his neck and dies in April 1417, which means that he's then succeeded by an even younger Dauphin who's even more inexperienced. And this is Charles, who is now the king's only surviving son. He's very sickly, he's very moody, very lacking in self-confidence, and he has very spindly legs. So he looks like a kind of spider as he moves. And, you know, I mean, he's wholly inexperienced and unqualified. I mean, spoiler alert, he will go on to become a very successful king in due course after Joan of Arc rallies to his cause. But at this point, he looks an absolute loser. And he very nearly gets wiped out because in April 1419, remember that Paris has come under the rule of the Count of Armagnac, and he's much hated because he has imposed his rule at the point of a sword.
甚至更像是一个乔治·雷蒙德·理查德·马丁式的血腥杀戮场，不是吗？是的，因为你会觉得也许死掉的王太子还不够，所以让我们再杀一个吧。这个倒霉的让王太子，也就是接替了那个胖乎乎的王太子的那位，他的脖子上长了一个脓肿，并于1417年4月去世，这意味着他随后由一个更年轻、更缺乏经验的王太子所取代。这就是查尔斯，他现在是国王唯一在世的儿子。他非常虚弱，非常喜怒无常，非常缺乏自信，而且他的腿非常细长。所以他移动时看起来像某种蜘蛛。而且，我的意思是，他完全缺乏经验和资格。我的意思是，剧透一下，在圣女贞德为他的事业振臂一呼后，他最终会在适当的时候成为一个非常成功的国王。但此时此刻，他看起来绝对是个失败者。而且他差点就被消灭了，因为在1419年4月，记住巴黎已经落入了阿马尼亚克伯爵的统治之下，他非常受恨，因为他是靠武力强加自己的统治。
He's got rid of all the butchers. He's got rid of all the butchers. So this means that there are lots of people within Paris who are prepared to side with the Burgundians. And in April 1419, a traitor opens the gates to a Burgundian hit squad. They enter the capital, and the whole city rises up against the Armagnacs. The count is captured, battered to death. People carve the salt tire, which is his emblem, onto his naked corpse. 2,000 of his followers are slaughtered. The Dauphin very easily could have been caught up amongst them, but he gets smuggled out by a loyal servant. And he
他赶走了所有的屠夫。他赶走了所有的屠夫。所以这意味着巴黎有很多人准备站在勃艮第人一边。在1419年4月，一个叛徒为勃艮第刺杀小队打开了城门。他们进入了首都，整个城市都起义反对阿马尼亚克派。伯爵被俘，被殴打至死。人们将他的标志——斜十字架刻在他的裸尸上。他的追随者中有2,000人被屠杀。王太子本来非常容易被卷入其中，但他被一个忠诚的仆人偷运出去，
escapes southwards to a town in central France called Bourges. And here he sets up his court. And in due course, he will come to be known derisively as the King of Bourges. And he will not return to Paris for 17 years. So Henry is now in charge of Normandy. John the Fearless is now in charge of Paris. And having possession of the French capital, John thinks, okay, I've got the English king on my doorstep. He's looking quite menacing. I've got the capital. Maybe it's time to switch sides, kind of build bridges with the Armagnacs, with the Dauphin, try and construct a kind of French resistance against Henry, this terrifyingly menacing opponent. And so the two sides do kind of put out feelers to each other. But Henry isn't really troubled by this. It's so easy to kind of make mischief, to play the two sides off against each other. And he's absolutely determined he's not going to allow the Burgundians and the Dauphin to constitute a serious opposition. Now, it is true that actually there is an in-person meeting between John the Fearless and the Dauphin on a causeway on the Seine, just outside Paris.
向南逃到了法国中部的一个叫布尔日的小城镇。在这里他建立了他的朝廷。随之，他将被嘲讽地称为布尔日国王。他在17年内都不会返回巴黎。所以亨利现在掌管着诺曼底。无畏的约翰现在掌管着巴黎。由于拥有法国首都，约翰心想，好吧，英格兰国王就在我家门口。他看起来很有威胁性。我占有了首都。也许是时候转换立场了，与阿马尼亚克派、与王太子搭起桥梁，试图组织一场针对亨利的法国抵抗运动，这个可怕而具有威胁性的对手。因此，双方确实向彼此发出了一些试探。但亨利并没有真正为此感到困扰。制造恶作剧、挑拨双方关系是如此容易。而且他绝对决心不让勃艮第人和王太子组成严肃的反对势力。现在，确实，无畏的约翰和王太子在巴黎郊外塞纳河的一条堤道上进行了一次面对面的会面。
But they don't agree much. But because this is now public, because it might seemingly seem a kind of propaganda blow against Henry, Henry's having none of it. Henry's response is now public, because it might seemingly seem a kind of propaganda blow against Henry, Henry's having none of it. Henry's response is, okay, no more Mr. Nice Guy. I am going to drive home to these two losers that I have preponderant force, that they cannot oppose me. And so he launches a full advance on Paris. And by the 3rd of August, 1419, the Duke of Clarence has occupied Saint-Denis, the great cathedral that is the Westminster Abbey of French royalty, where they're all buried. And then on the 10th of August, the English arrive outside the gates of Paris itself. And their arrival is so
但他们并没有达成太多协议。但因为这现在是公开的，因为它看起来似乎是对亨利的一次宣传打击，亨利根本不吃这一套。亨利现在的反应是，公开了，因为它看起来似乎是对亨利的一次宣传打击，亨利根本不吃这一套。亨利的回应是，好吧，不再装好人了。我要让这两个失败者明白，我拥有压倒性的武力，他们无法抗拒我。因此，他对巴黎发动了全面进攻。到1419年8月3日，克拉伦斯公爵已经占领了圣德尼，这座伟大的大教堂是法国皇室的威斯敏斯特修道院，他们都埋葬在那里。然后到了8月10日，英格兰人抵达了巴黎城门外。他们的到来是如此地
terrifying for the king. I mean, he's absolutely, he's in a terrible state by now, mind completely gone. But his servants bundle him out of the city as the Dauphin had earlier been bundled out with his queen and his daughter Catherine, and they flee to a town called Troyes, which is about 100 miles southeast of Paris. And there are many Parisians who are in such a state of despair that they're now actively willing Henry to occupy Paris. The condition of the city is so traumatic, so miserable that they feel Henry may be English, but he would at the very least impose order. You know, the Parisians have reached that state. This is the context, Tom. So John and the Dauphin now have a second meeting, don't they? So I remember reading about this when I was a boy
令国王感到恐惧。我的意思是，他绝对、他现在处于一种可怕的状态，脑子完全不正常了。但他的仆人们把他的王后和女儿凯瑟琳像之前王太子被裹挟出去一样，把他也裹挟出了城市，他们逃到了一个叫做特鲁瓦的城镇，大约在巴黎东南部100英里处。有许多巴黎人绝望到了这种地步，以至于他们现在积极地希望亨利占领巴黎。这座城市的状况是如此痛苦、如此悲惨，以至于他们觉得亨利可能是个英国人，但他至少能强加秩序。你知道的，巴黎人已经达到了那种状态。这就是背景，汤姆。所以约翰和王太子现在有了第二次会面，对吧？所以我记得当我还是个男孩时读到过这个
in, I don't know, some encyclopedia or something. And I thought this was a tremendous story. I don't know if there's been a French film about this, but it's one of the great set pieces in kind of French medieval history. They're meeting at Montereau, which is on this bridge, isn't it? And it's this kind of weird bridge with a kind of fenced wooden enclosure in the middle where they meet. It's built specifically so that the two sides can meet and they can be absolutely certain that there won't be any treachery. So the Dauphin, John the Fearless, their respective retinues, they both cross from either side of the banks and they meet in this kind of room that's been built on the middle of the bridge. And it's all very tightly controlled because obviously neither side trusts the other. So John the Fearless kneels before the Dauphin to signal his respect. And then he moves to rise. And as he does so, he puts his hand on his sword
在，我不知道，某种百科全书或类似的东西里。我认为这是一个了不起的故事。我不知道有没有关于这个的法国电影，但这可以说是法国中世纪历史上的伟大标志性场景之一。他们是在蒙特罗会面的，那是在这座桥上，对吧？这是一个奇怪的桥，中间有一个围起来的木制 enclosure（围栏），他们在那里会面。它是专门为了让双方会面而建造的，并且他们可以绝对确信不会有任何背叛。因此，王太子、无畏的约翰以及他们各自的随从，他们从两岸穿过去，在桥中间建造的这个房间里会面。这一切都受到极其严格的控制，因为显然双方都不信任对方。因此，无畏的约翰在王太子面前下跪以表示敬意。然后他起身，当他这么做时，他把手放在了剑上，
and the Dauphin's servants think that this is treason. And so they cut him down and he's left for dead. And whether it was a misunderstanding or whether it actually was treachery, there's no question that the Dauphin is blamed for it. He's seen as having betrayed his word. It's absolutely blot on his honour. And of course, it's a disaster for him because the Burgundians are now absolutely committed to an alliance with England. And John has a very able son, Philip, Philip the Good, who we talked about a lot in our episode with Bart Van Loo on the Burgundians. And although Philip doesn't sign up to the English alliance immediately, negotiations are going on. And by December 1419, he and Henry are going public and saying that they are called upon by God to punish the treacherous Dauphin
王太子的仆人们认为这是叛国。于是他们将他砍倒，他被认为必死无疑。无论这是一个误解还确实是一场背叛，毫无疑问，王太子为此受到了责难。他被视为背叛了自己的诺言。这绝对是他荣誉上的污点。当然，这对他是场灾难，因为勃艮第人现在绝对致力于与英格兰结盟。约翰有一个非常能干的儿子菲利普，也就是善良的菲利普，我们在与巴特·范·卢讨论勃艮第人的那一集里谈过很多次。尽管菲利普没有立即签署英格兰同盟，但谈判一直在进行。到1419年12月，他和亨利公开宣布，他们受到上帝的召唤去惩罚叛国的王太子
and to give God's peace to France. And they issue public proposals. And these proposals are that there should be peace between England and France, that Charles VI should remain king until he dies. And Henry's happy to sign up to that because he's a man who thinks that the anointing of a king should really mean something. You can't just depose Charles VI. But that Henry is to rule as regent and he is to marry Charles VI's daughter, Catherine. And that once Charles VI dies, the crown of France will pass to Henry and then to his heirs, which will also be Catherine's heirs. And that England and France are to be separate kingdoms, but to be joined under the one crown. And what this means effectively is that the Dauphin has been disinherited. That's a pretty good deal for Henry, isn't it?
并给法国带来上帝的和平。他们发表了公开提案。这些提案是：英格兰和法国之间应实现和平；查理六世应继续担任国王直至去世。亨利很高兴签署这个协议，因为他是一个认为国王的涂油礼应该真正具有某种意义的人。你不能就这样废黜查理六世。但是亨利将作为摄政王统治，他将娶查理六世的女儿凯瑟琳。一旦查理六世去世，法国的王位将传给亨利，然后传给他的继承人，这也将是凯瑟琳的继承人。英格兰和法国将是两个独立的王国，但在一个王冠下联合起来。这意味着实际上王太子被剥夺了继承权。对亨利来说，这是一桩相当不错的交易，不是吗？
It's an amazing deal. He would effectively rule France nominally under Charles VI. Then when Charles VI is gone, Henry is king of France and of England. He doesn't need to combine them into one kingdom. I mean, that would be a challenge. It would be a really big logistical and administrative challenge, but it's not impossible. I mean, there are lots of people in European history who ruled two realms. We'll come to that. And the Dauphin can do nothing about this. Like his father feels like he's got no choice. He's impotent. I think there is a case for saying that Henry overreaches with this, that the temptation is too great. He could have said, look, I'll take Normandy, I'll take
这是一桩惊人的交易。他在名义上受查理六世管辖下有效地统治法国。然后当查理六世离世后，亨利就是法国和英格兰的国王。他不需要把它们合并成一个王国。我的意思是，那将是一个挑战。那将是一个非常巨大的后勤和行政挑战，但这并非不可能。我的意思是，欧洲历史上有很多人统治过两个王国。我们稍后会谈到这一点。而王太子对此无能为力。就像他的父亲一样，他觉得别无选择。他是无能为力的。我认为有一种观点认为，亨利在这件事上做得太过火了，诱惑太大了。他本可以，看，我拿诺曼底，我拿
Aquitaine, that's fine, and just consolidate those and not reach for the crown. But he feels he's the apex predator who's got the equivalent of a goat tethered to a tree. Of course he's going to go for it. And Charles VI is helpless to oppose him. The Dauphin is powerless. And so essentially it's agreed. And on the 8th of May, 1420, Henry goes to Saint-Denis and he prays there amid the tombs of all the kings of France. And then he heads south to Troyes where Charles VI and his daughter Catherine are waiting. And two weeks later he arrives and on the outskirts of the town, he meets Philip the Good, first time they've met. And then on the 21st of May, what will be called the Treaty of Troyes is ratified in the cathedral of the city. And when Henry seals it, he does it with the seal that had been used by Edward III to seal the Treaty of Bretigny, which was the treaty that had given him a vast swathe of France, but had not given him the
阿基坦，这就够了，巩固这些就行了，不要去够王位。但他觉得自己是站在金字塔尖的掠食者，面前就像栓在树上的一只山羊。他当然会去捕食它。查理六世无力抵抗他。王太子也无能为力。所以基本上就这样敲定了。1420年5月8日，亨利前往圣德尼，在法国历代国王的陵墓中祈祷。然后他向南前往特鲁瓦，查理六世和他的女儿凯瑟琳在那里等候。两周后他抵达了，在城镇郊区，他见到了善良的菲利普，这是他们第一次见面。然后在5月21日，被称为《特鲁瓦条约》的协议在该市的大教堂获得批准。当亨利盖上印章时，他使用的是爱德华三世用来签署《布勒丁尼条约》的印章，那个条约曾赋予他法国的大片土地，但没有给他
crown. So Henry's Treaty of Troyes is a level of success beyond even that, that Edward III had won. I've gone one better than the greatest king in English medieval history. Yeah. And so after the treaty has been signed, they come out and the terms of the treaty are read to French crowd in French, and then to the English, the retinue in Henry's train in English. And on the 2nd of June, Henry marries Catherine. Catherine is how old? She's 19. Right.
王冠。所以亨利的《特鲁瓦条约》取得的成功甚至超越了爱德华三世曾经赢得的成就。我比英国中世纪历史上最伟大的国王还要出色。是的。所以条约签署后，他们走了出来，条约的条款用法语宣读给法国民众，然后用英语宣读给亨利随从中的英国随从。6月2日，亨利娶了凯瑟琳。凯瑟琳多大？她19岁。对。
Catherine is then given a train of English ladies to serve her. So it's quite Marie Antoinette, you know, going from Austria to France. The French queen is now going from France to England. The difference being that she's actually going up in the world rather than down. Yeah, well, you might want to say that. So December, the two royal families enter Paris. Henry visits Notre Dame, prays there. A Burgundian is given charge of the Louvre, and an Englishman is given charge of the Bastille. And most prisons accept this,
凯瑟琳随后被配备了一队英国贵妇来侍奉她。所以这很像玛丽·安托瓦内特，你知道的，从奥地利到法国。法国王后现在正从法国前往不同命运的英格兰。不同之处在于，她实际上是在过上更好的生活，而不是走下坡路。嗯，你可能会这么说。所以12月，两个王室进入巴黎。亨利访问巴黎圣母院，在那里祈祷。一个勃艮第人被委任掌管卢浮宫，一个英国人被委任掌管巴士底狱。大多数监狱都接受了这一点，
for the reasons that we've been saying. They're just relieved that, you know, the war and all the horror is over. And on the 1st of February, 1421, Henry arrives with Catherine at Dover. So it's the first time that the new Queen of England sees her realm. Henry, very keen to kind of impress her, to show off. So the entry into London, he's arranged for a giant mechanical head on London Bridge. Wow, who wouldn't be impressed by that?
原因正如我们一直所说的那样。他们只是感到宽慰，你知道的，战争和所有的恐怖都结束了。1421年2月1日，亨利带着凯瑟琳抵达多佛。所以这是英国新王后第一次看到她的王国。亨利非常热切地想给她留下深刻印象，想炫耀一番。因此进入伦敦时，他在伦敦桥上安排了一个巨大的机械头。哇，谁能不对此印象深刻呢？
Well, I think she is. A head of whom though? Just a giant mechanical head. Just a generic head. Right. And then shortly afterwards, she's crowned in Westminster Abbey. And then on the 6th of December, she gives birth to Henry's first child. And everyone's waiting to see, you know, is it going to be a girl or a boy?
嗯，我想她是的。究竟是谁的头？只是一个巨大的机械头。只是一个普通的头。对。然后不久之后，她在威斯敏斯特修道院加冕。接着在12月6日，她生下了亨利的第一个孩子。每个人都在等着看，你知道的，会是个女孩还是男孩？
And it's a boy. And he, with such a lineage, he would undoubtedly turn out to be a really formidable, strong-willed and impressive martial king,'t he yes and this basically sets the seal on unbelievable triumph for henry and for england so henry is now the regents of france he's the heir to the ruling king of france and now he has a son who can succeed him as king of france He's 35, so the presumption must be that he has many years of life ahead of him. He's by far the best soldier in Christendom. I mean, his military achievements are astonishing. He's an incredibly capable, effective, successful king. He understands what it is to rule. And so looking at him at this moment, you might think this is all going to work out
结果是个男孩。而且有着这样的血统，他毫无疑问会成长为一个真正强大、意志坚定且令人印象深刻的尚武国王，对吧？是的，这基本上给亨利和英格兰带来了难以置信的伟大胜利盖上了印章。所以亨利现在是法国的摄政王，他是法国现任国王的王位继承人，现在他有了一个儿子，可以继承他成为法国国王。他才35岁，所以可以推断他还有很多年的寿命。他堪称基督教世界里最出色的军人。我的意思是，他的军事成就是惊人的。他是一个极其能干、高效、成功的国王。他懂得如何进行统治。因此在这个时刻看着他，你可能会认为这一切都会进展得
brilliantly. But of course, it doesn't. And Dominic, you began this episode by reading from the epilogue of Henry V. And it's talking about how fortune made Henry's sword, by which the world's best garden he achieved. And then we omitted the final lines and of it left his son, Imperial Lord Henry VI, an infant band's crowned king of France and England. Did this king succeed? Whose state so many had the managing that they lost France and made his
非常辉煌。但当然，并没有。多米尼克，你在这一集开始时朗读了《亨利五世》的尾声。它谈到了命运是如何打造了亨利的剑，他借此夺得了世界上最好的花园。然后我们省略了最后几行：“并留下了他的儿子，帝国之君亨利六世，一个在襁褓中加冕的法国和英格兰国王。这位国王成功了吗？他的国家经历了如此多人的治理，以至于他们失去了法国，并使他的英格兰流血，
England bleed, which oft our stage hath shown and for for their sake, in your fair minds, let this acceptance take. So the ending of Henry V, this great heroic drama, is a sombre one, a dark one, a reminder that it was effectively all for nothing. And actually, even before Henry's death, things have begun to go a bit darker. So in March 1422, the Duke of Clarence, Henry's brother, is defeated in battle against an army that's essentially made of Scottish knights. And Clarence dies. The French are still too afraid to face Henry himself. But the king, he's kind of probing the French defences along the Loire. And he's a bit anxious about it.
正如我们的舞台常常展现的那样，为了他们的缘故，在你们的美好心灵中，请接受这一点。”所以《亨利五世》的结局，这部伟大的英雄戏剧，是一个阴郁、黑暗的结局，提醒人们这一切实际上都是徒劳。事实上，甚至在亨利去世之前，事情就已经开始变得有点黑暗了。因此，在1422年3月，克拉伦斯公爵，亨利的弟弟，在与一支主要由苏格兰骑士组成的军队的战斗中战败。克拉伦斯阵亡了。法国人仍然害怕面对亨利本人。但国王，他正在卢瓦尔河沿岸试探法国的防御。他对此感到有些焦虑。
He's starting to run a bit out of money. So when you say the French defences, this is because the Dauphin is still resisting. Yeah. So despite the Treaty of Troyes, there are still French forces in the field that have not given up. So Henry's job now is to squash resistance. And this is proving much more difficult than perhaps he had imagined. If he'd been content with the northern half of France, say, the Loire could form a kind of barrier. It would be a bit like Nazi-occupied France and Vichy France, say. Yeah. The Loire could form a kind of barrier. It would be a bit like Nazi-occupied France
他的资金开始有些短缺。所以当你说法国的防御时，这是因为王太子仍在抵抗。是的。因此，尽管有《特鲁瓦条约》，战场上仍然有不肯放弃的法国军队。所以亨利现在的工作是镇压抵抗。事实证明，这比他想象的要困难得多。如果他满足于法国北部的话，比如说，卢瓦尔河可以构成一种屏障。这有点像纳粹占领的法国和维希法国，比如说。是的。卢瓦尔河可以构成一种屏障。这有点像纳粹占领的法国
and Vichy France, something like that. But because he has proclaimed himself king of France, it's therefore his responsibility to reduce the whole kingdom, which means crossing the Loire and defeating the Dauphin. And had Henry lived, you know, he responds well to crises.
和维希法国，诸如此类。但因为他宣称自己是法国国王，所以征服整个王国就是他的责任，这意味着要跨越卢瓦尔河并击败王太子。如果亨利活着，你知道的，他对危机反应良好。
He might either have found a way to do it or, you know, he might have recalibrated his ambitions. He might have arrived at a kind of new treaty, but he doesn't because he falls ill and he dies. To give people a sense of that, he's campaigning all summer. This is only nine months after the birth of his son, two years since the Treaty of Troyes. He is campaigning. There's various sieges and whatnot at castles. And as is so often the way people are campaigning in the summer, people think he probably got dysentery or heat stroke or something like that. He's carried around in a litter and then he dies. Yeah. 31st of August, 1422. Yeah. And leaves the
他要么能找到办法做到这一点，要么，你知道的，他可能会重新调整自己的雄心。他可能会达成某种新条约，但他没有，因为他生病了并去世了。为了让人们对此有个概念，他在整个夏天都在进行军事行动。这仅仅是在他儿子出生后九个月，距离《特鲁瓦条约》签署两年。他仍在行军打仗。城堡有各种围攻等等。正如人们在夏天行军打仗时经常发生的那样，人们认为他可能得了痢疾或中暑之类。他被用担架抬着到处走，然后他就死了。是的。1422年8月31日。是的。留下了那个
son who, as you said, is only nine months old. And it's that that made me say that he was overrated king. Oh, because he got dysentery. No, the fact that he achieves this seeming impregnable success and then it all just melts away. And I think the consensus generally would be that that was always going to happen, that it was going to be impossible for England to swallow France, you know, like a kind of boa constrictor trying to swallow an elephant. It was never going to happen. Actually, reading about Henry in much greater depth than I've ever done before, I think you could kind of play devil's advocate. You could say that, you know, he's not just a great soldier. He is also an incredibly adept politician. He's perfectly capable, I think, you know, if crossing the is impossible of focusing on Normandy, focusing on the Northern reaches, focusing on Paris,
正如你所说，只有九个月大的儿子。正是这一点让我说他是一个被高估的国王。哦，因为他得了痢疾？不，事实上他取得了看似坚不可摧的成功，然后这一切却烟消云散了。我认为普遍的共识是，这注定会发生，英格兰要吞下法国是不可能的，就像蟒蛇试图吞下一头大象一样。这是永远不可能成功的。事实上，在比以往更深入地阅读了关于亨利的资料后，我想你可以扮演魔鬼的代言人。你可以说，你知道的，他不仅是一个伟大的军人。他也是一个极其精明的政治家。我认为他完全有能力，如果跨越河流是不可能的，就专注于诺曼底，专注于北部地区，专注于巴黎，
really making sure of his regime there, and then perhaps moving in later for the kill or arriving at some kind of accommodation. I mean, you could imagine that happening, I think. And the other thing is that Henry thinks hard about how his power should be projected and also how it should be protected. And I think that his emphasis on the fact that England and France will remain separate kingdoms, he's not aiming to integrate them, I think is very shrewd. It would have been the only way that he could have had success. Kind of like the union of England and Scotland, that the distinctiveness of the two kingdoms is a crucial part in persuading the peoples of the two kingdoms to accept the union. So to his French subjects, he projects himself as a model of justice, a man who can keep the peace.
真正确保他在那里的统治，然后再寻找时机发动致命一击或达成某种妥协。我的意思是，你可以想象这种情况发生，我认为。另一件事是，亨利深思熟虑地考虑了如何投射他的权力以及如何保护他的权力。我认为他强调英格兰和法国将保持为独立的王国，他并不打算将它们整合，这非常精明。这将是他取得成功的唯一途径。有点像英格兰和苏格兰的联合，两个王国的独特性质是说服两个王国的人民接受联合的关键部分。因此，对于他的法国臣民，他将自己投射为一个正义的模范，一个能够维护和平的人。
And he does have French admirers. You know, we've been saying he is the best option. To his English subjects, of course, there's a nervousness because Henry actually spends most of his reign in France, not in England. And so obviously they're worried. They don't want to lose their king to the French. And I think that you can see Henry's sensitivity to this. So it's why the terms of the Treaty of Troyes were written and promulgated by him to the English in English and not in French or Latin. And that's part of a much broader policy
他的确有法国崇拜者。你知道的，我们一直说他是最好的选择。对于他的英国臣民，当然有一种焦虑，因为亨利实际上大部分统治时间都在法国，而不是在英国。所以很显然他们很担心。他们不想失去他们的英国国王。我认为你可以看到亨利对此的敏感。因此，这就是为什么《特鲁瓦条约》的条款是由他以英语而不是法语或拉丁语写成并向英国人颁布的。这是更广泛政策的一部分，
to emphasise the fact that he is an English king. So the letters that he sends that are stamped, his diplomatic missives, his administrative documents, they are often written in English. And it creates something that had basically not been a feature of English administrative life since 1066, which is English language-based administration. And in a way of all the many achievements of Henry V's reign that turned to ash, his conquests and all of that, this I think is the most enduring legacy of Henry's reign. It was always going to happen, but he expedites it. The fact that English government and English administration properly becomes English, written and expressed in England. Well, Tom, since we're at the end of the series, maybe Theo will let us go on a tiny bit longer.
旨在强调他是一个英国国王的事实。因此他发送的盖章信件、外交使团文件、行政文件，通常都是用英语写的。这创造了自1066年以来基本上没有成为英国行政生活特征的东西，即以英语为基础的行政管理。在某种程度上，亨利五世统治时期化为灰烬的众多成就中，他的征服等等，我认为这是亨利统治时期最持久的遗留成果。这本来就会发生，但他加速了它。英国政府和英国行政管理真正成为英国的，在英国书写和表达的事实。好了，汤姆，既然我们到了这一集的尾声，也许西奥会让我们多聊一会儿。
So two things that occurred to me. The first thing, so this is the biggest turnaround in the history of The Rest is History. Certainly as far as you're concerned, that you've gone from, you know, I don't know, 50 episodes ago or 100 episodes ago saying Henry V was the most overrated king in English history. You were very vehement about it. And you said this was a self-indulgent, obviously impossible enterprise, unlike Edward III. And it was always going to fail. He wasted
所以我有两个想法。第一件事，所以这是《历史的其余部分》历史上最大的转变。当然就你而言，你从，你知道的，大概50集前或100集前说亨利五世是英国历史中最被高估的国王。你对此非常激烈。你说这是一个自我放纵的、显然不可能完成的事业，不像爱德华三世。这注定会失败。他在这项事业上浪费了
money and blood on this enterprise. And actually thinking about you talking about the dual kingdoms, I mean, actually in this period, there is a really good example of a dynasty that rules multiple kingdoms very successfully, which is obviously the Habsburgs. The Habsburgs end up running this gigantic patchwork empire of different kingdoms. Or indeed the Spanish king, you know, Ferdinand and Isabella. Right, exactly. They do so very successfully for a very long period of time. So it's not impossible, I would say, that if Henry V lives.
金钱和鲜血。实际上想想你谈到的双重王国，我的意思是，实际上在这个时期，有一个非常好的朝代成功统治多个王国的例子，那就是哈布斯堡王朝。哈布斯堡王朝最终统治了这个由不同王国组成的巨大拼凑帝国。或者实际上是西班牙国王，你知道的，斐迪南和伊莎贝拉。没错，正是如此。他们在很长一段时间内非常成功地做到了这一点。所以我想说，如果亨利五世活下来，这并非不可能。
I think it was always unlikely. And that's why I thought Henry V, he was never going to pull it off. But I do think having read about him, firstly, I mean, he's an amazingly competent king. He's really, really impressive. He's just really good at it. He's really good at it.
我认为这总是不太可能的。这就是为什么我认为亨利五世，他永远不可能成功。但我确实认为读过关于他的书后，首先，我的意思是，他是一个极其称职的国王。他真的，真的很让人印象深刻。他真的很擅长这个。他真的很擅长这个。
So KB Macfarlane, who was, you know, one of the great, great historians of the 15th century. I mean, he said Henry V was the greatest man that ever ruled England. I don't really want to talk in those terms, but Henry, I mean, he's a formidable man and he's a thoughtful man. You know, that sense that he had to promote an English identity in England and present himself as a properly French king in France, it sounds so obvious, but loads of kings wouldn't have thought to do that.
所以K·B·麦克法兰，他曾是，你知道的，15世纪最伟大、最伟大的历史学家之一。我的意思是，他说亨利五世是统治过英格兰的最伟大的人。我其实不想用这种词来谈论，但亨利，我的意思是，他是一个令人敬畏的人，也是一个有思想的人。你知道的，那种他必须在英格兰弘扬英国认同感，而在法国表现得像个地道的法国国王的感觉，听起来太明显了，但很多国王不会想到去这样做。
I mean, Henry VI and his regime don't really do that, but Henry does it. So had he lived, maybe there's a possibility that he might just have worked. I mean, it probably wouldn't in the long run, but I still think it was a waste. Obviously it was a waste. It was all for nothing.
我的意思是，亨利六世和他的政权并没有真正做到这一点，但亨利做到了。所以如果他活着，也许有可能这真的行得通。我的意思是，从长远来看可能行不通，但我仍然认为那是一种浪费。这显然是一种浪费。这一切都是徒劳的。
All that blood, all that gold, all that suffering. Yeah. But Henry's not to know that. You know, we can't sit in judgment from posterity. No. And your counter-argument to that gold, all that suffering. But Henry's not to know that. We can't sit in judgment from posterity. No. And your counter-argument to that is, it's easy for us in the 21st century to say, what a waste of blood and money and effort and whatnot. But the two things are, one, that is what is expected of a medieval king. His nobles, they want excitement, booty, expansion, all of that. And if you fail to deliver deliver that people will judge you for it
所有的鲜血，所有的黄金，所有的苦难。是的，但亨利并不知道这一点。你知道的，我们不能站在后代的立场上妄下断言。不。你对那种“黄金，所有的苦难。但亨利并不知道这一点。我们不能站在后代的立场上妄下断言。不。”的对立观点是，我们身处21世纪，很容易说这是对鲜血、金钱和精力的巨大浪费等等。但两点是：第一，这是对一个中世纪国王的期望。他的贵族们，他们想要刺激、战利品、扩张，所有这些。如果你未能兑现这一点，人们就会因此对你评头论足，
and it will endanger your regime and secondly if you are the son of a usurper and your regime is insecure you probably have no choice yeah busy giddy minds with foreign quarrels exactly but the third is and this is what i always try and remember you know, is that you have to judge the moral standards of the age by its own moral standards. And Henry clearly thinks that he is chosen by God to be the king of France. And that being so, the sin would not be to invade France, but not to invade France. And I don't think that's just hypocrisy. I don't think that's just kind of Machiavellian humbug. I think he genuinely believes it. And Agincourt is's just hypocrisy. I don't think that's just kind of Machiavellian humbug. I think he genuinely believes it.
这会危及你的政权；第二，如果你是一个篡位者的儿子，你的政权并不稳固，你可能别无选择。是的，用对外纷争来填补狂热轻率的心灵，正是如此。但第三点是——这也是我总是努力去记住的，你知道的，那就是你必须以那个时代的道德标准来评判那个时代的道德标准。亨利显然认为他是被上帝选中成为法国国王的。既然如此，罪孽将不是入侵法国，而是不去入侵法国。我不认为这仅仅是伪善。我不认为这只是某种马基雅维利式的虚伪。我认为他是真诚地相信这一点的。阿琴库尔战役就是
And Agincourt is the proof of that. He's put it to the test and he has spectacularly won. Well, Tom, a wonderful series. Thank you very much. I've really enjoyed doing this. So in 1422, Henry has tragically died and he's left a nine-month-old son on the throne of England. And Tom, we would be remiss if we did not pick up this story maybe next year with the reign of henry the sixth theo will finally get his way and we will finally tell the sad and sorry story of the english defeats in france that mark the end of the
最好的证明。他经受了考验，并且获得了无与伦比的胜利。好了，汤姆，这是一个精彩的系列节目。非常感谢你。我真的很享受录制这个。所以到了1422年，亨利不幸去世了，他在英格兰王位上留下了一个九个月大的儿子。汤姆，如果我们不在明年左右重新拾起这个故事，讲述亨利六世的统治，那我们就失职了。西奥终于如愿以偿，我们将最终讲述法国战役中英格兰失败的悲惨故事，那标志着
hundred years war and then of course the beginning of the great medieval soap opera the greatest medieval soap opera them all the story of the wars of the roses so soap opera the greatest medieval soap opera them all the story of the wars of the roses so that will be coming at the rest is history and when it does of course tom rest is history club members will get it all in one go won't they they will so that's something to look forward to yeah so i imagine we'll be uh looking first of all at joan of arc which of course is one of the most extraordinary stories oh no i thought we were going to skip joan of arc that's shocking that's shocking no we're not going to skip Joan of Arc. That's shocking. That's shocking.
百年战争的结束，然后当然是伟大中世纪肥皂剧的开场——所有中世纪肥皂剧中最大的一部，也就是玫瑰战争的故事。所以这些将会在《历史的其余部分》中推出，当它推出时，当然，汤姆，“历史的其余部分”俱乐部成员可以一次性全部收听，对吧？他们会的，所以这绝对是值得期待的。是的，所以我想我们首先会关注圣女贞德，这当然是极其非凡的故事之一。哦，不，我以为我们要跳过圣女贞德呢。太令人震惊了，太令人震惊了。不，我们不会跳过圣女贞德。这太令人震惊了。这太令人震惊了。
No, we're not going to skip Joan of Arc. One of the most extraordinary stories, not just of medieval history, but of all time. I can hear Theo giving a Gaelic laugh from here. Right, on that bombshell, Tom, merci beaucoup. A veritable tour de force as always. And everybody, we will see you next time for something completely different.
不，我们绝不会跳过圣女贞德。不仅在中世纪历史上，而且在所有时代中最非凡的故事之一。我仿佛能听到西奥从这里发出盖尔语的笑声。好啦，带着这个重磅炸弹，汤姆，非常感谢。一如既往的真正的力作。各位，我们下次再见，聊点完全不同的东西。
Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works.
再见。再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的其余部分》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、以及一点八卦八卦的好去处。在我们的问答环节，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。
We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外单集以及提前购买现场门票的权限，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。